una polémica que según sus críticos pone
bajo la mira el sesgo de la
radiotelevisión nacional británica la
bbc recibió represalias del público tras
suspender al presentador de deportes
garylineker de su programa de fútbol
match of the day tras el tweet del
presentador en el que criticaba el plan
del gobierno para frenar la inmigración
irregular no hay una gran afluencia
acogemos a muchos menos refugiados que
otros grandes países europeos Esto no es
más que una política
inconmensurablemente cruel dirigida a
las personas más vulnerables en un
lenguaje que no difiere del utilizado
por Alemania en los años 30 y yo estoy
fuera de lugar el director de la bbc
Team David defendió la decisión alegando
que el neker había violado las normas de
imparcialidad de la organización
se trata del equilibrio entre la
libertad de expresión y la imparcialidad
y sinceramente no creo que se trate de
la izquierda o la derecha se trata de
nuestra capacidad somos fervientes
Defensores del debate democrático de la
Libertad expresión Pero eso conlleva la
necesidad de crear una organización
Imparcial
presentadores y otros periodistas se
negaron a trabajar en Solidaridad con
lineker obligando a la bbc a reducir su
cobertura deportiva este fin de semana
el público también acusó la emisora de
parcialidad política y de reprimir la
libertad de expresión después de que
sacara del aire a su presentador mejor
pagado creo que la reacción del número
de personas que han dicho que no van a
actuar en televisión hoy demuestra la
fuerza del sentimiento de que estaban
completamente fuera del lugar al hacer
eso el Primer Ministro Richie sunak
sigue defendiendo su plan para impedir
que los inmigrantes en situación
irregular soliciten asilo en el Reino
Unido el líder conservador instó a la
bbc y a Gary lineaker a resolver
rápidamente su disputa